Let's discuss an example of SPD and
SADB.
Recall that in transfer mode,
the traffic is protected end to end,
whereas internal mode,
the traffic is protected
between the gateway of one network
to the gateway of another network.
First, let's consider the end to end,
or transfer mode policy from A to B.
Suppose the policy says that for
any traffic from A to B,
the packets need to be authenticated.
And further,
the suggested algorithm is to use HMAC
with MD5 as the embedded hash function.
This policy is stored
as an entry in SPD.
The negotiated parameters, again A and
B, are store in SA in both A and
B's SADB.
For A's SADB,
it stores a secret key for HMAC and
SPI for looking up the SA in B's SADB.
Then when A sends out traffic to B it
can include this SPI in the IPsec header
so that B can use it to look up
the SA and un-process the traffic.
Now let's take a look at
the tunnel mode traffic
from the subnet that A belongs to,
to the subnet that B belongs to.
Suppose the policy says that for any
traffic From A's subnet to B's subnet,
the tunnel's destination
is B's gateway which is D,
and the data should be encrypted,
therefore ESP should be used,
and further, 3DES is requested.
Since C is the gateway of
the subnet that A belongs to,
C's SPD stores this policy.
And its SADB stores the SA
that has a 3DES key.
And SPI, for
looking up SA in these SADB.